[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de tv
fil 78 touati et les titres en images de
ce 21 février 2010 est elle la toute
première édition du jumping
international de versailles se déroulera
du 4 au 7 mai les meilleurs cavaliers du
monde
elles s'affronteront dans le cadre
majestueux de la grande écurie du roi
présentation de l'événement ce matin
depuis la cité royale en présence du
parrain guillaume canet hommes
politiques et le candidat sortant
menacés dans la 10e circonscription des
yvelines gilles schmit adjoint udi au
maire de rambouillet se présente face à
jean frédéric poisson déjà désignés par
les républicains et puis c'est une
profession qui se retrouve mise en
lumière en raison de l'actualité celle
d'assistant parlementaire en quoi
consiste ce métier rencontre avec
fabienne vitaux elle travaille aux côtés
du député françois de mazières depuis à
2012 paris ou los angeles le nom de la
ville hôte pour les prochains jeux
olympiques de 2024 sera dévoilée le 13
septembre en attendant à la campagne de
promotion se poursuit notamment dans les
yvelines un département particulièrement
impliquée dans cette candidature
aujourd'hui le comité olympique
départemental faisaient un point d'étape
depuis le vélodrome national de mathilde
de 2 min sur des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude
en attendant le choix de la ville
organisatrice pour les jo de 2024 la
promotion passe par paris mais aussi
dans les yvelines
ce 21 février c'est au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin que les
différents sites retenus pour accueillir
les épreuves ont été présentés ce n'est
pas seulement paris c'est toute la
france qui souhaite qu'ils souhaitent
avoir les jo et je crois que le cyclisme
sa partie prenante et nécessaire à la
contribution qu'elle doit apporter
vis-à-vis du sport en général ils nous
nous battons donc aux côtés du comité
national olympique et sportif français
pour qu'ils aient justement
ces jouets quatre sites sont au coeur du
dispositif dans les yvelines à
versailles notamment pour les épreuves
équestres
le vélodrome nationale à montigny le
bretonneux la colline d'elancourt mais
aussi au golf national à guyancourt
c'est très très important puisque nous
avons un sport qui est toujours
considéré comme un peu à la fois
élitiste et confidentiel le fait qu'ils
soient revenues dans les jeux olympiques
montre que c'est un sport qui peut se
démocratiser pour toucher le plus grand
nombre de personnes évidemment nous
soutenons la candidature de paris aux
jeux puisque nous avons des
infrastructures qui nous permettent
d'accueillir cette belle épreuve
des expositions seront installés pour
valoriser les bills yvelinoise et des
actions de communication seront établis
dès le mois de mars avec un seul
objectif mettre toutes les chances du
côté de paris et en attendant les jeux
olympiques les amoureux de sport
pourront profiter d'un rendez vous
majeur d'équitation dans les prochaines
semaines la toute première édition du
jumping international de versailles va
se dérouler du 4 au 7 mai 2010 est les
meilleurs cavaliers du monde vont s
affronter
présentation ce matin en compagnie du
parrain lui aussi amoureux du cheval
guillaume canet imaginez-vous plus de
2000 personnes réunies dans cette cour
des grandes écuries du roi à versailles
ajoutez à cela les meilleurs cavaliers
mondiaux et vous obtiendrez l'un des
tournois les plus prestigieux de cette
année 2010 est en france le jumping
international 5 étoiles a été présenté
officiellement aujourd'hui dans la cité
royale en présence des organisateurs des
sportifs et de l'acteur guillaume canet
ambassadeurs de l'événement
l'idée de ramener le cheval à l'endroit
du cheval de l'époque de louis xiv et
bien sûr qu'on pourrait ici ne faire
qu'un concours prestigieux en ramenant
l'excellence déjà il ya une curiosité
d'avoir envie de voir un peu ce lieu et
ce cadre et puis et puis voir du
spectacle parce qu'il ya des meilleurs
cavaliers mondiaux ça va ça va aller
vite et haut
parmi les têtes d'affiché françaises on
retrouvera notamment le champion
olympiques 2016 kevin stunt originaire
du chéné grand père paternel amis tennis
je venais très régulièrement dans mon
enfance ensuite une fierté pour
l'équitation française arrivée en
conduire organisé un concours de cinq
étoiles donc du plus haut niveau
ici dans un lieu mythique dans les
écuries du roi c'est extraordinaire du 4
au 7 mai vers cei va avoir des allures
de centres équestres géant de son
chevaux seront visibles dans les rues de
la commune
on veut aussi faire partager aux
versaillais aux gens de la région
ce qu'est notre sport on a en a la
chance aujourd'hui de s'appuyer sur une
équipe championne olympique et qu'on va
présenter aux gens le prix des places
sera annoncé le 7 mars le même jour que
le lancement officiel du site internet
du concours
on quitte le domaine du sport pour celui
de l'emploi à la 21e semaine de l'emploi
et de la formation débute ce jeudi
différents événements seront organisés
pour permettre au public demandeurs
d'emploi jeunes ou encore ceux qui
souhaitent évoluer professionnellement
de s'informer de s'orienter de découvrir
les métiers qui recrutent ce sera à
saint quentin en yvelines et nous
recevions hier en plateau sur ce plateau
erwan le gall est élu à 50 ans en charge
de ces questions écouter et les patrons
répond présent à la semaine de l'emploi
ils y vont vraiment oui alors
j'ai rien inventé je suis arrivé aux
commandes jury lui il ya une chose qui
s'inverse il tendance qui s'inverse
c'est ça quand en yvelines terre
d'innovation et le développement
économique et est force de proposition
est très dynamique et donc les chefs
d'entreprise reprennent confiance aux
politiques très important c'est à dire
que je vais voir des chefs d'entreprise
je vais voir des entreprises
je vais voir des centres de formation
nous discutons donc oui ils viennent
volontiers mais de toute façon il ya du
chômage en france
mais il ya aussi un besoin de main
d'oeuvre il ya un besoin de techniciens
il ya un besoin d'ingénieurs propre
programme complet de cette semaine de
l'emploi sur le site internet de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines législatives
l'adjoint au maire de rambouillet jean
schmitt s'est donc être déclarés
candidats dans la 10e circonscription
une candidature focaliser sur ses idées
elles centriste nicolas landry était
présent pour le lancement de campagne
gilles schmidt a choisi la salle des
fêtes d'orphin pour déclarer sa
candidature aux élections législatives
lui entouré de ses proches
il a tenu un discours fidèle à ses
convictions centristes et il me semblait
important d'être à côté d'un de mes amis
pour le lancement de sa campagne parce
que on partage des valeurs humaines des
valeurs politiques ensemble et je pense
qu'on a une envie commune farouche de
faire de la politique autrement
gilles mas
c'est ce grand plaisir de me proposer
d'être sa suppléante de l'accompagner
dans cette belle aventure
et j'avoue que c'était le candidat que
j'aurais soutenu de toutes façons dans
une circonscription aux couleurs rural
les enjeux liés à ce territoire seront
au coeur de sa campagne
j'ai décidé de candidats pour participer
au débat démocratique
pour animer ce débat qui aujourd'hui
ne remplit pas ne répond pas à mes
attentes et ne remplit pas ne répond pas
aux attentes de beaucoup concitoyens
concernant la ruralité le travail qu'on
va le mener c'est tout un travail
effectivement de maillage travail de
transport travail d'accès aussi de
réseaux internet
la fibre on va travailler aussi sur
l'accès à la culture à la formation à
l'emploi
prochaine étape pour gilles schmitt
obtenir l'investiture de lui dit
en cas de refus du parti il maintiendra
tout de même sa candidature dans la 10e
circonscription et ira défier le député
sortant et président du parti chrétien
démocrate jean frédéric poisson et en
cas de soutien de l'ue dia gilles schmid
jean frédéric poisson devrait donc une
nouvelle fois voir rouge voici quelques
jours c'est son vice président xavier
lemoine pour qui l'investiture à
montfermeil s'envolaient au profit des
centristes
je ne laisserai pas faire ce que je
considère comme une forme d'agression
avait-il déclaré
la détention également du côté des longs
cours mais cette fois ci entre le maire
et son opposition au conseil municipal
cette dernière lui reproche la hausse de
son d'indemnités annuelles pour frais de
représentation de 10000 euros une
décision indécente pour les élus de
gauche dans un contexte de restrictions
budgétaires
réponse de l'équipe majoritaire par la
voix de son premier adjoint
dans un courrier adressé aux habitants
de la commune il s'agit je cite de
polémiques inventé de toutes pièces par
des opposants municipaux peu scrupuleux
une plainte pour diffamation à l'égard
de personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique
elle devrait être déposée
[Musique]
l'actualité secoue aussi la fonction
d'attaché parlementaire nous sommes
allés a rencontré fabienne vitaux
collaboratrice dû être député françois
de mazières dans la circonscription ou
encore à l'assemblée elle est
essentielle au travail du parlementaire
le reportage de michael et demi d'euros
julie barenton et nicolas dendre lecture
de dossiers législatifs signature de
documents administratifs appels
téléphoniques le quotidien de fabienne
vitaux à 49 ans elle est assistante
parlementaire du député des yvelines
françois de mazières depuis le début de
son mandat
installé dans les bureaux à versailles
elle relaye les demandes des citoyens de
la première circonscription des yvelines
on est en contact constant avec la
circonscription avec les services de
françois de mazières en mairie avec la
préfecture donc en fonction des
sollicitations sur des logements sur des
problèmes d'emploi sur les problèmes de
trafic de réseau sncf qui ne fonctionne
pas c'est un sujet qui interpelle les
administrés fabienne s'occupe de la
communication sur le web
pour elle c'est une vocation elle ne
compte pas ses heures de travail
c'est passionnant c'est vraiment
passionnant mais c'est passionnant aussi
parce que parce que c'est un député qui
donnent la main qui fait confiance et
une fois que la confiance est établie
c'est du bonheur c'est votre composition
de l'ouest sur la nature donc ça c'est
pourquoi vous ont pris une position
est ce que vous faites est cosignée à
cette ppl mise au pas confirmé c'est un
très gros travail de préparation d'abord
d'examen de toutes les propositions
d'amendement de textes qui nous arrive
est très régulièrement
et puis ensuite j'ai pris pour
l'opposition les spécialistes questions
culturelles
je suis très souvent intervenu dans les
débats parlementaires - présentation des
budgets
l'autre volet de son activité se déroule
ici dans les bureaux de l'hémicycle
fabienne vitaux y consacrent une grande
partie de son temps de travail
originaire de franche-comté elle passe
son baccalauréat et devient secrétaire
médicale elle reprend des études de
droit public obtient le niveau d ea et
décide de rentrer dans l'administration
j'ai souhaité me consacrer en fait aux
services publics parce que j'ai toujours
voulu travailler pour l'intérêt général
et donc j'ai passé différents concours
administratifs et j'ai obtenu celui
enfin un concours pour entrer au
secrétariat général du gouvernement donc
être à la disposition des premiers
ministres servir les autres c'est
essentiel et travailler pour l'état pour
moi c'est important et au travers de
françois de mazières aujourd'hui je
considère que je continue à travailler
pour l'état
elle a notamment travaillé au cabinet du
premier ministre
occasion pour elle de rencontrer
françois de mazières alors conseiller
communication et culture auprès du chef
du gouvernement
c'est le début de leur collaboration
fabienne devient ensuite son assistante
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale
sa principale tâche ici faciliter le
travail du parlementaire pour ses prises
de parole en commission ou en séance
publique
donc dans toutes ses interventions en
commissions culture on lui prépare des
notes des éléments de langage nous
veillons sur l'actualité au quotidien
pour l'informer et nous rédigions des
armes
françois de mazières a décidé de ne pas
briguer un nouveau mandat de
parlementaire
fabienne restera sa collaboratrice pour
une autre mission sinon elle retournera
à matignon pour poursuivre sa vocation
servir l'état un tout autre sujet à
présent loisirs nous en parlions hier
les trophées de robotique se déroulait à
saint quentin en yvelines plusieurs
équipes locales ont brillé montigny
repart avec le prix du développement
durable et rap avec une qualification
pour la finale nationale des 1er et 2
avril le trophée de robotique permet
chaque année aux jeunes de 7 à 18 ans de
mettre en valeur innovation inventivité
un travail mené conjointement avec leurs
enseignants reportage complet à revoir
sur notre site internet
et puis pour terminer ce journal hameaux
de culture avec l'ouverture ce mardi
soir du festival féminin pluriel afin de
soutenir l la création féminine le
réseau de théâtre en yvelines créative a
lancé l'opération
plusieurs rendez vous jusqu'au 1er avril
à travers le département pas moins de 29
spectacle et de cinquante deux
représentations ce soir ce sera au prix
smile en cours avec la compagnie burn
out dès 20h30 écouter à la marraine du
festival l'humoriste sophia aram elle
revient brièvement sur son parcours et
sur son engagement en tant que femme
dans cette profession
un jour une fille m'a dit je faisais de
l'improvisation théâtrale à l'époque et
je démarrais et elle m'a dit parce
qu'elle me trouver un petit petit petit
peu fragile une petite chose comme ça et
je mal dit ma fille pour réussir dans ce
métier faut des couilles et l'or comme
c'était pas au programme la greffe de
testicules j'avais pas du tout
usa comme ambition dans ma vie je
m'étais dit que j'allais faire avec mes
ovaires et que ça n'allait pas du tout
me poser de problèmes dans la vie et au
contraire ça va et ça a été un vrai
moteur pour moi de prouver que ok j'ai
pas de couilles mais je vais y aller
quand même
fin du journal as a retrouvé en replay
sur notre site internet et sur notre
application mobile très belle soirée sur
tv fils
[Musique]